now this starts to get more tricky when
you have a look at these other ones
right so I think from memory you've got
one that says X y equals six does anyone
put into desmos yet yeah okay if you
haven't already like Zacky please put it
in X y equals six does anyone remember
the name of this shape it has a name
it's a hyperbola right X y equals six
might look a little more familiar in
this form y equals six divided by x I
divide both sides by X right so I'm
sorry this is really messy so I'd
encourage you by the way desmos has
drawn this for you but I'm still going
to encourage you to um just do your own
rough drawing like a small one in your
book because obviously you're going to
shut your computer down and you want to
know where did this air to come from
right yep XY equals six this is the one
we're looking at I think it'd look
something like this yeah yep
okay now here's where it starts to get
more interesting right what values of X
let's just think about extra myths
that's horizontal what values of X can
we put in what values can't we put in
and you want to suggest yeah go ahead
yeah okay hold on a second there's a lot
in that answer right I can't put in
don't forget x equals zero it's a
vertical line
all right there's x equals zero you
can't put x equals zero in because when
you put in x equals zero what happens
you're dividing by zero and just like
before your calculator is going to have
a fit and say you can't do that you're
gonna break the break the rules of the
universe right so we're not allowed to
go there we heard this forward this
special word right this asymptote thing
this is a part of the graph that we get
closer and closer and closer to but we
never exactly get there which is why you
can see I sort of taper off before I
reach it okay so therefore when I say
the domain right Jack did you have a
question or a suggestion yeah different
could be any value other than 0 in fact
I'm actually gonna write that down
because I think it's such a clear answer
any value except for whoops this is a
totally acceptable way to write this
answer ok but just like before it might
sort of seem to you quiet long and wordy
right now just look up for a minute and
don't write this down but I want you to
watch what I'm doing here's how not to
answer this question X kind equals zero
right X can be any value except for zero
so X can't equal zero now it's tempting
to write that it's succinct it seems to
capture all the information that you
want the only problem is think back what
does domain mean what was the definition
I gave you before right it's all the X
values where the function exists yeah
can I say that again the domain is all
the X values where the function exists
this is the x value where the function
doesn't exist right it's the opposite so
if you ask me what my favorite food was
and I said to you I hate durian because
I do and if you don't know what it is
count yourself lucky but it's a smelly
fruit that's spiky and it fell if it
fell on you you would die if I told you
that I haven't answered the question
have I have not told you what my
favorite food is you have not told me
what the domain is you actually have to
provide me more information that ok now
if you I'm getting rid of it cos wrong
if you don't want to use quite so many
words here's another way you could say
it X could be less than zero right this
is X is less than zero over here to the
left or X could be more than zero that's
from here to the right and that's it
cheers what's conspicuously absent from
my inequality signs what's missing
yeah it's that it's the equal to bit or
the equal to bit I'm deliberately
leaving it off I'm excluding it does
that make sense so this answer is like
everything to the left everything to
right mister
yeah what do these mean yeah for this
graph here yep so if I try some X values
so long as they're bigger than zero I
can put them into this and I'll get some
answers out right like for example here
um pick a value that's bigger than zero
anyone shattered in itself any of you
like four you're going to get one and a
half so you have a y value it works give
me another one and I value bigger than
zero three I had three that's - I'm
gonna get values I can put in eight I
can put zero point four I can put
anything I like so long story as it's
bigger than zero does that make sense I
can do if it's negative - good question
this is the concept I was talking about
I'm so glad you asked when I say he's x
equals zero as I start looking at what
these numbers are right actually do this
with me if you were to label your axes
what might you label these as yeah 1 2 3
4 5 etc right so these are all the
numbers bigger than zero so that's why
I'm going off to the right does that
make sense bigger greater than going
that way less savannahs over here
negative 1 negative 2 negative 3
negative 4 negative 5 you get the idea
the less of that means go to the left
okay in the context of horizontals okay
do you think you could answer for me
what the range is range it up and down
right and it's basically the same isn't
it it's got the same problem we call it
an asymptote right a place where the
graph gets closer and closer it doesn't
quite get there so I'm gonna write it
very similar for range with one subtle
difference instead of X's y is y is less
than zero or Y is greater than zero okay
all right now you're starting to see ok
I get this right I can see there are
some patterns here I don't have to keep
on drawing this thing I can actually
just look at the way this is written see
how there's an X on the journal area
that means you can't divide by zero so X
is not allowed to be zero right so on
your table there
let me help you work this out we've got
the top down the coordinates they're the
X and the Y's the axes are horizontal
and vertical the values where the
function exists the name we give to
these things our domain and range okay
so it's kind of nice just coincidentally
everything ends up being in alphabetical
order right so domain comes first then
range X and then Y okay so now when you
have a look at the bottom here right to
work out domain and range it's usually
easy to think about the places that
break down the place where it stops
working
so we've already noticed for example
square roots square roots what would you
write in there right when you see a
square root like this guy we're not
allowed to take the square roots of
negative numbers right so I would say
whatever is underneath the square root
can't be negative okay in fact that's
good that's why I've given you such a
big space in the box there that's what I
would write whatever is underneath the
square root is not allowed to be
negative okay so that's square roots
quadratics we start off with this guy
right now how could we work out the
domain and range without having to draw
this thing right well what I would say
is whenever you have something squared
right this is what I put in that box the
smallest square can be if you have
something like x squared the smallest
value that can take on is zero right if
you square something whether it's
positive or negative the smallest it's
going to be is 0 right if you take a
really teeny tiny number and you square
it you'll still be a bit above zero
right so can you see when you have a
look at this right the smallest this
part can be is zero so that means you're
five and above do you see how I got the
range out of that this squared part the
smallest it can be is zero so I always
have to be above that I'm gonna leave
off the rest of those to see what you
would conclude right if you have a
rational function that's like uh-oh like
see like this one well you've got
something divided by something else
that's
numbers of fractions right your
denominator your denominator is not
allowed to be what what are we not
allowed to divide by zero right you
can't divide by zero so that's why I'd
write under there the logs and the
Exponential's we might come back to
those but you could graph those using
desmos and you can look and maybe you
can tell me where the domain and range
are allowed to be okay